james abaresque represented south dakota
in the u.s senate from 1972 to 1978.
he sat down for this book notes
interview in 1990 to discuss his
political memoir advise and dissent it's
about an hour
former senator james averisk author of
advise and dissent memoirs of a south
dakota and u.s senator
you say that i've always thought that
those who are defined as mainstream or
the establishment are the real outsiders
they are the ones who are ultimately
destructive to our society what do you
mean by that
well if you
if you would track how the what i call
the establishment has
taken over
every aspect of this country's politics
of its society
of its communications virtually every
aspect
and have
twisted you know the initial
the original intention of the founding
fathers and of the people of this
country to their own use and their own
benefit
and have made everything else virtually
illegal or unpopular one way or the
other that's what i mean by it
just to give you an example
for example the oil companies the
multinational oil companies
have uh have made it
unpopular to criticize what they do by
virtue of dipping into the pockets
of the public you know for example i'm
referring specifically to the
deregulation of natural gas
they made it appear as though this is
the only course for this country yet
what they did was they came to the
congress and they got the congress to
pass legislation allowing them to raise
the prices of natural gas
which as in effect really gouged the
public i mean i look at my own gas bill
where i used to pay eighty ninety
dollars a month it's now two or three
hundred dollars a month for the same
kind of gas usage in the for a furnace
in the wintertime and it's things of
that nature of the people who own
television networks now who absolutely
instead of using television networks to
educate the people as television was
originally designed to do such as c-span
does
for example they use it as a selling
medium that's all they do there's
nothing you you can't
uh you can't see a program but what
there isn't selling going on i mean it
just that's all it is just a selling
medium and it's used for commercial
absolutely commercial purposes there is
very little education if any at all and
those are just two examples were you
ever worried at any time when you were a
united states senator for six years that
you were starting to become a member of
the establishment no i don't think i
have worried about a lot of things but
that was not one of them no i was afraid
if i stayed around too long and ran for
too many terms that might happen that's
why i decided one of the reasons i
decided to get out early you served in
the house and the senate both for a term
what were those years
well between 71 and 73 in the house and
73 and 79 in the senate
is life better since you've left the
senate well for me it is yes i'm not
sure it is for palestinians or indians
but it certainly is for me why do you
say that
well i'm you know i'm i'm not subject to
the scheduling whims of my staff or my
constituents or my
contributors anymore
now i run my own schedule i have my own
time if i go somewhere it's because i
want to not because i'm forced to
but i
i do feel that a bit of responsibility
for
the vulnerable and the weak in this
country that i used to try to represent
to my best ability but i'm not there
representing them anymore for example
indian people
consumers
palestinians who are stateless
you live where now i live in washington
now and do what for a living i practice
law and i write books for a living and
why did you write this book
um well i could say for the money except
i didn't make very much money on it but
no actually i i think it's important to
uh to try to detail to people especially
young people especially young arab
americans which i'm one
i'm not a young arab american
but
especially for young arab americans to
know that they can
maintain their principles
and get into american society get into
american politics without selling off
their principles
and uh and be successful in that in
whatever regard they want to be i think
it's a good object lesson for people of
my ethnic group and for people in
general
you talk about a thing that was called
abscam that upset you the name abscam
why
well it was initially called either i
think abdul scam or arab scam
i had a a reporter the day after the ab
scam thing broke in the in the
newspapers
a reporter from the washington post
called me and said what do you think of
the word arab scam
and i said what do you think of the word
jew scam and she said well it sounds
terrible i said well i think it does too
and i think that's
how arab scam sounds
and
i started getting telephone calls from
arab americans around the country who
were outraged because the fbi director
had said somewhere
when asked why did he pick an uh
an arab to dress up the he had actually
had an italian-american fbi agent dress
up as an arab this is william webster
webster yes
uh and he was asked somewhere
why he had picked uh an arab to dress up
his fellow ass
and he said we had to find some ethnic
group that the public would believe is
capable of corrupting our politicians i
mean it was really i mean i i thought we
had hit bottom by then
that there was really nowhere else to go
except up
and uh there were so many incensed arab
americans about this that i decided the
time was right to form a committee to
combat
stereotyping and discrimination against
people of arab descent
when did you start that
that was 1980
i held the first organizing meeting in
may of 1980
excuse me i opened my first office in
september of 1980.
today the american arab
anti-discrimination committee which i'm
still the chairman of
uh has 25 000 members or more and we're
organized into over 65 chapters around
the united states we're a national
organization now
and that's our
primary function is to combat
stereotyping and discrimination
and uh to
ask for fairness in the media and all
these aspects including coverage of the
middle east conflict which we think is
important to arkansas the book is
advised and dissent the author is james
average
a united states senator and united
states
house of representatives member in the
70s
where'd your father come from
he emigrated here from lebanon in 1898
i went to uh he went to south dakota i
think he had an older brother there
or a younger brother one one of his
brothers was there he went there and
eventually became a homesteader and a
merchant and he peddled
spices and linens from a pack on his
back as so many immigrants did
and
eventually he opened a store in 1913 on
the rosebud indian reservation in south
dakota
and then in 1920 when my mother finally
came over he'd gone back to marry her in
the meantime and they had a couple of
kids
she came in 1920 which is the same year
that he opened his second store on the
same reservation
and where's your mother from she's from
lebanon he went back to lebanon and
found her as she was 20 years younger
than he was
married her they had my older brother
and sister and then he came out were
they both from the same village yes oh
yeah well that's natural you would never
go outside of your village over there to
find a wife right
why is that i don't know that's just the
way things work what do you most
remember about your dad
well that he was a very generous very uh
uh he was quite a wonderful guy you know
he would give you the shirt off his back
if he had five dollars he'd give you
4.95
and uh he when he lost his temper which
was uh quite often he would lose it for
three minutes and then totally forget
about what he'd lost his temper about
but he uh he kept a lot of people alive
during the depression out in woods south
dakota just by giving them
credit
in the grocery store
and never expecting payment of course
nobody had much money back then
he went bank he took bankruptcy two or
three times
just because of his good heartedness
what do you most remember about your
mother
that she was tough she had grown up
virtually by herself and raised the two
kids my brother and sister by herself
during world war one
in southern lebanon
and which i think gave her a lot of
toughness and she came off she came to
this country being very tough
and when my father died in 1951 she then
lived another 22 years
by herself and she lived most of her
life by herself practically your dad
when you're when you were born your dad
was quite old for he was 60 when i was
born and he lived to be
at 79.
and you started out life speaking arabic
in south dakota yes well my mother spoke
only arabic she didn't speak any english
when i was born
so
naturally i spoke arabic until i started
school
and you know i started drifting away
from it and forgot i've forgotten most
of it now unfortunately
what was it
who taught you the the uh arab
philosophy of life or the traditions and
all was it strictly your mother and
father well i it was just my mother and
father what little tradition i learned
was from them but you have to understand
we lived in the prairie of south dakota
there were very few other arabic
families out there in fact the only one
real close by was the abdenner family
senator jim abner came out of that
family
we had uh actually we held two seats the
lebanese seat in
the senate was held by both abner and
myself
uh for except he was a republican
unfortunately
uh
what is this in your opinion the source
of the
strong feelings between the arabs and
the jews well i don't think there's any
strong feeling between arabs and jews as
such it's strong feelings the arabs have
about the israelis coming in to move
them out of their land to take their
land away from them
by force of arms and and the brutal way
in which the palestinians and the
lebanese have been treated ever since
then
that's the uh that's the source of the
hard feelings it has nothing to do with
the ethnicity at all
or religion
and in this country
the image that the arabs have in the
eyes of most americans is what in your
opinion i think it's been a very low
image which is one reason i organized
adc the american arab
anti-discrimination committee
i think the image is either that of a
high
high-spending
greedy
spendthrift arab shake or a terrorist
arab terrorist
and these are images that have been
propounded i think by the israeli lobby
and i think
uh quite effectively
they've done it just simply for their
own political purposes
the the purpose in my view of the
israeli lobby is twofold one is to make
certain that the flow of american
taxpayers money goes from our treasury
to israel that it's uninterrupted
and the other job that the lobby has is
to prevent any real negative information
or news about israel from filtering back
to this country they've had a little
harder time preventing that in recent
years
what with their invasion of lebanon in
1982 the brutality that they committed
there and now the brutality that they're
committing in the west bank against the
palestinians as a result of the uprising
against their occupation there
so
they're getting a lot of bad press
lately they deserve an awful lot more
bad press because
basically the coverage is sanitized
uh they don't show ten percent of what's
really happening there i mean there's
there's a prison camp ketchiat prison
in the desert in the negev desert that
uh holds some three or four thousand
palestinian political prisoners it's all
they are as political prisoners they're
kept in the heat or in the cold of the
winter and the heat of the summer
without adequate water without adequate
ventilation
uh it's a it's a brutal brutal existence
for people who disagree with israel's
occupation
what is a palestinian
well a palestinian arab is someone of
arab descent who was born in palestine
or who lives there now
so if you live in the west bank or you
live in gaza or you could could you be a
palestinian and live in egypt could you
live in jordan i mean well yes
palestinians now have been dispersed all
over the world as a result of israel's
invasion
of palestine in 1948. how many
palestinians are there in the world my
guess is there's about three or four
million i'm not exactly sure
three or four million uh all around you
know i'm not exactly sure the number but
they live now in lebanon syria all
through the middle east many in the
united states in england all through
europe
uh they've been they've been kicked out
there a lot in south america that i've
met from south america
have you traveled to israel
i've been there once 1973. how did they
receive you
very coolly
and why was that i don't know why i have
no idea but it was a very cool reception
you've traveled throughout the middle
east oh yes yes
is the problem over there in your
opinion solvable and if it is how will
it be solved i think it's uh it's
solvable and i think
what it really is now is that
israel is the obstacle to a peace
agreement between the arab states
between the plo and israel
everybody's reached out the plo's
reached out further than anybody to try
to make a peace agreement
uh
israel is is intransigent
and the reason that they are is that
they they know for certain that if they
start negotiating with the plo the end
result of that negotiation will be a
peace agreement but they'll also have to
give up the west bank and gaza strip
which they don't want to do
and so they're
you know they're sort of erecting the
barricades out as far away from
israel as they can in other words
what i'm saying is they won't talk to
the plo they come up with every excuse
not to talk
they say we won't talk to the people
well the plo's our enemy
and if you want to settle if you want to
make peace who do you talk to and say
you don't talk to your friends you talk
to your enemies
so basically they're saying we don't
want to talk to our enemy therefore
they're against peace you know
in your book you say not long after i
left the senate to return to civilian
life i attended a backyard party hosted
by washington post reporter walter
pincus
and his wife
kay graham who owns the post walked over
to me during the party and hissed
are you representing a lot of rich arabs
now
you reacted strongly to that and why
would you say well i said uh
uh i can't remember exactly what i said
right now but i i know that i know that
mrs graham would never have gone up to a
a republican or a jew and would have
said are you representing a lot of rich
jews or rich republicans like i mean you
know it's uh
it's a bit of a stereotyping and
operation and it's unfortunate the owner
of a great newspaper has to have that
mentality that mental attitude
that's tragic what does that say about
people who are less educated or less
fortunate
people who are proper and decent don't
speak out on behalf of palestinians or
against the israeli government you wrote
that that's out of context why were you
well what i'm saying was i i'm seen as
an intruder
by people in the establishment of which
mrs graham is a member
i'm seen as an intruder because i make
them feel uncomfortable with my position
my political positions
and as i said people who stand up for
palestinians or whole hold the oil
company's feet to the fire are not
really
accepted into the establishment and i
think it's a good thing
the plo
good organization
well
what do you mean by good i mean compared
to what do you like what they do uh do
you have respect for us
yeah he's a good politician
yasser arafat is quite an extraordinary
politician having had survived all these
years after assassination attempts and
by
enemies in from israel as well as from
enemies in the radical wing of the plo
i have i think he's an extraordinary
politician
uh he's uh he's seen by palestinians as
their leader he's the guy who brought
them where they are today
a lot of them don't like yasser arafat
they think that he hasn't managed the
plo properly but still they say if he's
an sob he's our sob
we wouldn't be anywhere without yasser
arafat i'm i don't even know he may or
may not be president of palestine
whenever that becomes a state who knows
but whatever it is that they'll always
remember what he did for them talk about
terrorists and and not just on one side
or the other but
have
the has the plo take undertaking any
terrorist activities
at the same time have the israelis
undertaken any terrorist activities yeah
i the israelis have undertaken a number
of terrorist activities and have i'd i'd
say the ratio
of the
lebanese and palestinians and others
that they've killed that the israelis
have killed
as opposed to how many the palestinians
have killed is a ratio of 50 to one
the israelis have killed 50 times more
arabs than the
than the palestinians have ever killed
of israelis at what time when at any
time you want to i mean through you know
through the whole history
i have
somewhere in my files at home a white
paper issued by the israeli foreign
ministry called the threat of plo
terrorism in which they detail they say
that since 1969 when arafat took over
the plo there have been 600 plus maybe
650 israelis killed by plo terrorism
well i can document 25 000
25 000
uh palestinians and lebanese who have
been killed by israeli terrorism in that
same period of time and i haven't
documented in another book that i wrote
called through different eyes by the way
and when you say 25 000 give us an
example of what you're talking about
well 18 000 were killed in the lebanese
invasion of 1982
when israel
invaded in lebanon and killed that many
civilians these are not soldiers these
are civilians
of all the bombing raids they've gone
for the bombing raids have gone on for
15 or 20 years
and they've killed
you know hundreds and hundreds of
civilians in those bombing raids
uh they uh massacred 1948 by the way
the urgoon and the stern gang together
which menachem began and shamir were in
charge of at that time they were jewish
terrorist groups in 1948 massacred an
entire village called dariasin
of
243 some civilians were murdered by
those terrorist groups
and on and on and on i mean there's just
there's a whole litany of uh
of terrorist activities in the part of
israel and yet the uh the complaint i
have is the propaganda in this country
is that that only palestinians are
terrorists
and yet when
israel as a state commits acts of
terrorism
they hide it you know they hide behind
the fact that they say we're securing
our state well
uh the palestinians are securing
themselves too you might say
why has the israeli lobby been so
successful well they're well organized
they're well financed and they've been
added an awful long time
and when they uh when they
when they work on the congress when they
move on the congress uh they understand
very well how to get to a congressman
they know where the politically
erogenous zone is and that's money
campaign money early campaign money
so the lobby itself knows how to make
campaign contributions and to whom
and they use the threat of contributions
either for you or against you to keep
you in line keep you voting for money
taxpayers money to go to israel
and people are you know politicians are
generally very cowardly
and they don't want the controversy that
might be involved in attacking the
israeli lobby or going against their
wishes
politicians would rather have that money
coming into their campaign rather than
their opponents campaign can you buy a
politician
well not outright
i i wouldn't say outright but i think
you can get a politician's support by
virtue of the kind the size of the
campaign contributions that you can put
into his or her campaign did you ever
feel like that you had an obligation to
anyone when you're in the senate after
somebody contributed your campaign no i
never did actually i've had people who
contributed to me who demanded my
support later on if i didn't think it
was the right thing to do i would
i would not vote that way i i made a few
enemies that way i'd guess
people are used to buying access and
support that way i think in the congress
what would you do about the whole
business of
money and politics if you could change
things well i think the the most
critical thing is the the way elections
are financed
i would
make illegal all private contributions
and take
campaign money out of the treasury
and i would uh
shorten the time of campaigns by
limiting television advertising
and i would require that the television
networks provide free equal time to
candidates who are running for office
and i will i think i would also say that
if
a candidate wants to bad mouth or smear
another candidate that they'd be
required to do so in person
so that you don't have an anonymous
announcer attacking and smearing and
throwing mud at somebody
where the candidate who's hired that
announcer is standing back away from the
battle
and doesn't get any of the mud on
himself or herself i think if you
required candidates to do their smearing
by themselves they wouldn't do nearly as
much
i think it's very important because
simply it keeps good people from running
these smear campaigns do
and i think it turns off the public
i think it makes them
not want to take part in elections the
public
so
people who argue against
public financing of campaigns
on the grounds that it's too expensive i
think tend to overlook how expensive
private financing is let's take the
savings and loan scandals
i mean they're we'll probably wind up
paying 200 billion
perhaps even more nobody knows for sure
how much
the bailout of the savings loan are
going to cost us but the laxity and
regulation i think is directly due to
congressmen and senators who intervened
on the behalf of the savings alone with
the regulatory agency
and made them slack off in the
regulation which then allowed them to
defraud the public the way they have
been
so that's what 200 billion you could
finance campaigns into the next century
with that kind of money
that's only one scandal there many
around that we don't even know about
that we won't find out for years yet i
want to come back to the whole
palestinian question but uh here's a
line from your book the nature of the
congress has changed since i stepped
down in 1979.
there were more politicians then who
were willing to try to slow the rush of
the greedy and the hungry but no longer
what kind of people are there now
well i like to call them uh sanfori's
pre-shrunk
blow-dried
poll reading
you know finger-to-the-win politicians
for the most part there are still a few
people who up there who act viscerally
who react this really
uh to issues you know that in other
words if you believe in an issue you do
it you don't go out and read a poll and
say how does the public feel today
because the public changes its mind
depending on the news that it's fed
so
i i think politicians read polls much
too frequently and worry too much about
their everyday day-to-day image instead
of using their good sound political
judgment
to vote on an issue today that may be
unpopular but that may be good for the
country in the long run
do you try do you lobby the congress now
no i don't lobby i never did lobby you
don't you don't even contact them on
behalf of the
arab causes oh no once in a while i'll
contact them and say will you come and
make a speech at our convention
and or i'll say you know uh
i wrote a letter to the congress
recently uh suggesting that allowing
soviet immigration soviet jewish
immigration into the west bank would be
destabilizing in the entire area simply
because i believe
that it would displace palestinians if
this immigration were allowed to go on
into the it's illegal you know to allow
immigration into an occupied land
and uh i think the congress is the only
entity that can really stop that because
there
the congress is the entity that can say
to israel don't do it or we won't give
you any more money israel lives on the
united states you know
and all the congress would have to do is
get some courage and stand up and say no
more you know stop doing this illegal
stuff what would happen if the 3.2
billion dollars in foreign aid were
withdrawn
uh well israel would have to cut a deal
from israel uh yeah they'd have to cut a
deal make peace tomorrow
they'd have to they'd have to really sit
down and talk but the reason they're not
talking peace now is because they don't
have to they're getting rewarded by the
congress no matter what they do no
matter what sins they commit
or what crimes they commit they get
rewarded well what happened to egypt if
we were through the two billion dollars
not much
i understand not a lot of that money
gets the egyptian people anyhow it goes
to consultants and
and the rich in egypt anyhow so it
doesn't bother me so you think that the
whole camp david agreements and the idea
of paying both of those countries uh
that kind of foreign aid was a bad one
oh that's bad we've been paying israel
before camp david egypt that's i i
consider that part of israel's aid bill
anyhow the 2.8 billion we pay egypt
simply because that's a bribe to keep
egypt from attacking israel
because if you if you saw that if egypt
did attack israel tomorrow the congress
would withdraw that money tomorrow
so you can't call it anything but a
bribe in fact
how often do you find yourself
representing the
uh
the american arab anti-discrimination
adc adc it's a lot of words how do you
how often do you find yourself getting
mad
and wanting to do something about it and
when you do what is it that you want to
reach out and correct something
well every day
i i get angry over something every day
you know angry in the respect that it's
frustrating to see the kind of press
coverage that you get give me an example
or you don't get
for example here's uh let's
let's not talk about press coverage
right now let me talk about the congress
and how it has a double standard
when the chinese government brutalized
their own students
last year in tiananmen square
of course everyone in congress is up on
their feet making a speech about it but
when israel brutalizes palestinian
children you know they're killing kids
two years old five years old 14 years
old just shooting you know at random
and killing these kids over there there
is total silence up in the congress now
that makes me uh very angry
not a word is set up here by these
so-called great human rights advocates
that you see in the senate in the house
not a word why not well because they're
afraid of the israeli lobby
they're intimidated because they want to
make sure the money keeps coming but you
say they can't be bought
i said not directly
i said you can indirectly buy somebody
by making sure they get a lot of
campaign by you can buy their support
by getting making sure that they get the
campaign contributions they want
what do you say to the
reasons that are often given that
israel is the only real democracy in the
middle east
well i don't know how you can call it a
democracy uh everybody in the west bank
and gaza strip is not only prevented
from voting
but they're kept virtually imprisoned
there i don't know how you can call that
a democracy it's a democracy for
jews in israel just like south africa is
a democracy for whites in south africa
so if you want to call south africa
democracy i guess you could call israel
a democracy what about the 750 000 arabs
that are citizens of israel well those
yes they can vote but they're treated as
second-class citizens though see most of
the benefits provided by the israeli
government to the citizens of israel
depend on whether you've served in the
military or not
and arabs are not permitted to serve in
the military i can understand that but
to discriminate on benefits put out by
the government that's another question
altogether that's that's wrong it's
unfair where did all this start oh what
start this
commitment to israel i mean in your
opinion and for what reason and why does
it just keep on going well i think i
think america and its politicians felt
guilty
about what happened to jews during world
war ii and they felt guilty because the
united states did nothing to help during
world war ii we turned away jewish
refugees in their late thirties and
early forties were trying to escape
hitler's pogroms
we turned them away from our shores
would not let them come here
and uh many of them went back and were
massacred by hitler
and i think there's that was one of the
great evils one of the black marks of
our democracy here
but i think there's a lot of guilt over
that i think there's a lot of guilt by
american jews because they weren't able
to doing enough to save jews over in
europe from hitler
and i think that operated in 1948 along
with the jewish terrorist groups who
were cleaning out the palestinians you
know scaring them off killing them
trying to get them to empty out
palestine
i think that combined with what was
happening politically here because of
the guilt
combined and created in the creation of
israel and declaring itself a state on
palestinian land
israelis will tell you today that
they're getting a real bad treatment in
the american media oh well sure they'd
say that what's happening is the media
is finally starting to cover what they
do about 10 of what they do
so i i mean they're spoiled you know
basically they're very spoiled
uh so any press coverage that's negative
they're going to complain about what
would you do if you were an israeli of
course
has your
it's your side but has have the arabs
gotten better coverage in recent years
and i don't think the arabs have i think
what's happened is that the press has
covered the uprising the intifada
and they've seen what's happening here
are kids throwing rocks and israelis
shooting bullets in return
you know americans are basically fair
people so when they see this kind of
thing it turns them off right they get
angry
they're not angry enough yet to pressure
their congressmen but i would hope at
some point they would
when uh congressman joe kennedy ran for
against seven other
people i think in this district up in
massachusetts the son of robert kennedy
you wrote him a check for a hundred
dollars
yes he had he was an old friend of mine
actually joe was young joe a young joe
yeah and he had sent a solicitation out
for money for his campaign so i sent him
a hundred dollars
about three months later his campaign
manager called me and said we're going
to send the money back
i said well why
uh he said well uh we don't uh we don't
take money from pax i said well i'm not
a pack i'm an individual i said in fact
that's my money in fact i you know i had
to scratch around to find the money i
didn't have much money at that point
and he said well we don't want to get
involved in the middle east this way
i said well you're i'm not asking you to
get involved in any way i said joe's a
friend of mine i want him to have this
money to run on you know to help him
[Music]
in his election
and so i said well i'll tell you what
you send the money back and you tell joe
that if he ever needs my help again he
can stuff it
and uh so i held a press conference a
few days later
and by that time joe was calling me
saying oh jim i didn't know about this
you know i'm sorry and so and so on
uh actually joe
learned a lot he went to the west bank
last year
or maybe a year and a half ago something
like that and came back i think with a
totally different view of the middle
east question when he when he saw what
the israelis were doing
and he came to our adc's national
convention about a year ago and made a
speech
i introduced him at the speech he got up
and apologized for doing what he had
done in returning my money it was
basically a slap in the face it was an
insult
but i think he's learned an awful lot i
think he's grown up an awful lot of in
that regard his uncle senator ted
kennedy
and you were friends yes friends and
allies still
well i'd say we're still friends i'm not
sure we're allies anymore what happened
well i think we've
split pretty much on the middle east
question i think ted has just gone off
the deep end on that question
his position today
i'm not sure what it is
in any event i heard him a year or so
ago
announcing on the radio that he thought
the plo offices ought to be closed in
this country closed down well you know
that's a that's a fascist point of view
and i told him so
back in during the hostage crisis
with iran
you got involved
what'd you do uh i was actually general
counsel for the government of iran here
in washington at that time for the
embassy here in washington
uh after the about two weeks after the
embassy was taken over
i decided i'd go over and try to get
obtain the release of the hostages
so i went over and i uh i negotiated
with bonnie sauder who was in chairman
of the revolutionary council
and
i worked out a deal with him i what the
iranians wanted was to air their
grievances against the united states of
which they had many at that time by the
way
you know we had supported the shah while
he was torturing and killing
iranian citizens
they had found by the way in the
basement of the american embassy a cia
counterfeiting operation counterfeiting
american money they were very upset
about that uh iranian money not american
money
and
uh so anyhow knowing this i i said to
bonnie soder look if you want to air
your grievances
i think in return for the release of the
hostages that i can get the u.s senate
to hold big publicized hearings allowing
you to do just that
well we worked out a deal to be a
three-step deal where we would announce
the hearings he would release the
hostages and then we would have the
hearings
and he said all right you
take that to the senate and i'll take it
to the revolutionary council we'll try
to we'll try to work it through
so i called senator byrd who was of west
virginia who was then uh majority leader
and uh proposed it to him i called him
from iran then when i got back from iran
i called him up and he said well the
administration is opposed to that kind
of a thing
because jimmy carter at that time was
was standing tough he was trying to look
like he didn't want to negotiate
and my view was look uh you know i don't
care who you negotiate if you've got
hostages who are suffering
you'll negotiate with anybody to try to
get them out
it's not to say you have to lose your
dignity
but it means that you truly should try
to do what you can for people who are
taken hostage
well
in any event they they turned the deal
down the administration did and the
foreign relations committee i think
objected to it as well on the grounds
that carter should be allowed to handle
the situation
i said well
bob i said you'd think that carter might
give you the approval under the table
and still be against it in public if he
wanted to be but let us try to get the
hostages out and he said well we have to
stay with what the president wants
i you know i'm convinced to this day
that that carter and his people
uh were running against ted kennedy by
the way in the primaries and i think
what he wanted to do was
was hang on to this hostage issue
until he got kennedy out of the race
because his popularity was going up and
kennedy's was going down as a result of
the hostage thing
so i think uh you know i think they
passed up a chance who knows whether it
would have worked but at least they
passed up that chance
you say in your book though that um
there was a meeting held
with some of ted kennedy's aides people
that are well known in this country
because they used to be jack kennedy
that was later on like ted sorensen and
your friend former senator john culver
of iowa where they wanted you to go to
iran and try to get some hostages
released to ted kennedy for what reason
and did you do well uh yes yeah that was
later that was after my first trip
uh they came to me on behalf of ted
kennedy and said
that they would like to
they would like to
have me go over and see if iran would
release some hostages on his behalf
release them
release them all
why would they want to do that well
because uh
kennedy was running against carter and
things were not going so well in the
election so they needed some kind of a
boost in the election
and i said sure you know i was
supporting kennedy right so i went back
over and of course that failed as well
were you at all concerned that you were
getting
close to stepping over the line with the
logan act and all that getting involved
in foreign policy for political reasons
didn't bother me
no
[Music]
i mean i would have loved to have been
put in jail for trying to release
hostages right i don't think they would
have done anything but
it would have not been would not have
been very politic on the part of the
administration
were you surprised that senator kennedy
wanted to use that crisis for political
reasons no no not any more than i was at
carter was using it for his political
reasons
politicians do that sort of thing brian
the baltimore jewish times uh reporter
arthur
magada magda
did
something with this story published it
yeah well he came and did an interview
with me he wanted to do a story on me a
profile
and uh when i read the profile all of a
sudden i saw in the uh in the profile
that an unnamed kennedy staffer told him
i think it was tom dine
who is who's now the director of aipac
which is the central focus of the
israeli lobby
i think tom dine was on kennedy's staff
at that time
dyan had told him or whoever it was i
guess it was dyne
told him that told magata that i
approached kennedy
and asked for money in return for going
after hostages
and which was a lie a bald-faced lie and
maggot of course apologized for it they
run a retraction on it but that's the
sort of thing the israeli lobby does the
you know what you'd call perfidy's right
and left
the senate club
you tell a lot of stories about the
senators that some have gone
one of them in particular was jim
eastland of mississippi you write a lot
about him one of my favorites
did you agree politically with him not
on any one issue that i can remember
who was he
jim eastland was a senator from
mississippi
i think a classical racist
who ran against blacks you know against
on the black issue
i think from the time he started
politics of course that's how you did
things in mississippi back then i think
but jim was always up front i mean you
knew what he was he didn't try to
pretend he was anything else
and
he ran the judiciary committee very
handily very easily
every
democrat who came on the committee was
given a subcommittee and some staff
and of course all of us on the judiciary
committee appreciated that
he even gave a republican a subcommittee
while he was chairman roman ruska from
nebraska
you tell the story about how you used to
go there's a special room that
oh yeah
jim uh actually jim there was a room it
was this the room belonging to the
secretary of the senate well who
occupied it
above the senate floor in the third
floor and there used to be a small group
of senators ted kennedy
john pastore eastland
myself i started going up there
we'd take a drink now and then the
afternoon
jim easton furnished the scotch i think
he had the cotton council
send it up all the time
uh in any event
we would sit up there and hold court and
start talking about different issues and
every time i'd walk in it reminded the
senators sitting there about american
indians because i was a champion of the
indians
and
so they'd start talking about indians
and
oh i think past story spoke about this
one day past story spoke about what he
thought about them and somebody else
didn't pastor he was from rhode island
rhode island yeah and jim easton came
out of his chair and he said
i never saw an indian woman who wasn't
virtuous and he sat back down and jim
never talked very much you know he was a
quiet very quiet man what was the source
of his power and his
seniority is anybody does anybody have
that kind of power there today
i don't know i don't know i would doubt
it i would doubt it he was chairman of
the appropriations committee no he was
chairman of judiciary
um
and
today is it strictly seniority like it
was then well it's still seniority yeah
but i mean
why do you doubt that he would have that
uh kind of well i think people are more
people are a bit more rebellious now
than they were back then
i think the seniority system was was a
lot tighter than it is now
you um you write a lot about jimmy
carter
well i had a lot of experience with
jimmy carter
you like him oh i like him he's all
right i i you know he's when you look at
reagan and bush uh he comes off uh
looking a lot better now than he did
back then
he said he was he was far from being a
good president it was all right you know
his entire national career was based on
sniffing the wind to see what was
momentarily popular
a technique that he tempered with a
pious attitude that he thought would
carry him past the political rough spots
yeah that's that's jimmy carter
you got it to him this was
these are your words not mine to him
this was the way smart politics was done
but to the public he appeared weak an
image that presidents cannot convey and
remain popular
the best comparison i can offer is that
of ronald reagan what's the comparison
well the comparison is ronald reagan
stood for things that most of the public
did not agree with
i mean they didn't agree with his you
know
cutting taxes for the rich and his
unemployment program when he was trying
to
try to bring interest rates down and so
on
but yet he seemed very strong he gave
the image of being a strong decisive
president
and even though the public didn't agree
with what he said they liked how he did
it so he there thereby retained his
popularity now carter on the other hand
the issues that he came out with i think
people generally agreed with them
but because he conveyed this image of a
vacillating weak president
he lost tremendous popularity as a
result of it
this is what the book looks like it's
called advice and dissent and
we are talking to the author of this
book who is former senator james
abresque of south dakota
who published your book lawrence hill
books in new york
why'd you choose them
uh well you know they made an offer to
publish the book and i accepted it how's
the book selling it's selling quite well
they're in their second printing now of
hardcover printing
and uh i expect we'll go into paperback
printing after this uh after this run is
finished
because a lot of people have called the
publisher and said you know we want to
buy it but we can't afford the bits what
1895
and they wait they want to wait a little
paperback comes out but
nevertheless
the book is selling quite well the
reviews have been excellent how much
interest are you getting in the talk
shows around the country to have you
come on and talk about this a lot i've
done oh my gosh i guess about 30 or 40
talk shows
i did a tour book tour in
october and november of last year and
part of december
and i did 40 cities then there's an
awful lot of interest in the book
and any what's the reference what's the
reaction to the audience about the whole
jewish
arab issue
you know it's strange i've been going on
talk shows for years about this issue i
used to get an awful lot of flack
and i was on for example the larry king
show here not very long ago
in uh well it was in january yeah in
january
and
i have to tell you there was very little
opposition to what i was saying ever
most most of the calls that came in were
calls in agreement in fact jim bohannon
who was the guest host that night had to
start apologizing to the audience the
calls were so favorable he said look i'm
just taking these in order this is not a
setup which i thought was interesting
because i he was he also was surprised
and he was used to uh people calling him
and attacking anybody with my point of
view in the middle east i think things
are changing
and what do you point to is the reason
for that the uprising
the intifada the uprising and the and
the press coverage of what little press
coverage that's come out of the indifada
has really turned people around in this
country
uh
there's one interesting that it pertains
to this network's reason why i wanted to
ask you about this
uh
back i'm trying i see the page here but
i can't remember the hearing it says
i was usually the only senator senator
president at committee hearings so
occasionally i resorted to one of my old
tricks to bring
uh other committee members out of the
hearings out for the hearings i would
ask john thorn to set up tv lights and
an inoperative tv camera yes
did you really do that oh yeah sure when
you were in the senate oh yeah you'd
have you'd have lights and camera a
camera set up for what reason well to uh
but there would be senators wouldn't
come to these hearings
uh unless they themselves were chairman
of some committee but they wouldn't come
to the ones i was so
uh they would come if they thought there
was television there
so i'd set up the empty camera and the
lights and so on and their staffs would
run to the phone and call them they'd
start coming they'd show up for the
hearing for a while and leave again but
that's a way to get them to attend the
hearings how often did this happen oh a
few times you know didn't do it all the
time but a few times
were you as cynical going into the
united states senate as you were coming
out no of course not
of course not did you ever think going
in that you were going to stay there
no i never thought about how long i
would stay but about a year after i was
in i decided that i would not run again
what were some of the things you know
what you know what a cynic is you know
of course you go from idealism to
cynicism but a cynic is someone who if
he sees a bouquet of flowers looks
around for the casket
so that's what happens if you stay in
politics too long right
speaking of caskets
senator former senator john culver from
iowa
i know what you're saying
is cited in your book as being a
practical joker
well oh he just did a few not too many
you know john john told me when he read
my book he said jim he says i've tried
to build my reputation for 20 years and
you tore it down with one book
but john was a very funny guy by the way
very brilliant guy very funny
he walked in senator mcclellan was
sleeping on the
sofa in the cloakroom one day former
senator mcclellan now deceased from
arkansas
john was uh mcclellan was there snoring
you know sleeping in the back of the
senate in behind the senate floor
cover walked in looked at him and he
said why don't we just get a bouquet of
lilies
and take the chairman out into the
rotunda and let him lie and stayed out
there for a while
senator randolph
oh he did the same thing to random
virtually the same thing was during that
all-night filibuster
bird was the filibuster of the natural
gas bill bird had kept us in all night
long
and about three in the morning jennings
randolph was sound asleep on this same
sofa and culver went over and shook him
and he said
jennings he said there's a group of high
school students from west virginia out
there want their picture with you and
jennings who was in his 70s by the way
jumped up straightened his hair out in
his tie and went out in the corridor to
find the students
and he came back in instead of
denouncing culver he said well he said
some of these younger guys look a little
sleepy
he says i think i'll just talk a while
and give them a chance to rest so he
stood up and gave a two or three hour
recitation on the history of the natural
gas bill
of natural gas regulation it was an
amazing performance i thought
the prize for lack of humor would have
to be shared with a number of senators
you write
but south carolina senator strom thurman
is strongly in the running
why well uh strom took over as chairman
of judiciary in 1981 when the
republicans took the majority
and i ran into him up in the cloak room
and i said well congratulations you know
we served on the committee together when
i was in
i said congratulations strom i said you
know i'm going to take down my picture
of ted kennedy who was chairman
and i'm going to put yours up in his
place and strom instead of you know
laughing at the joke
said don't do that he said it's going to
hurt ted's feelings
and when you were in the senate
it could get pretty rough at times
well in what respect the debate
see you had some experiences where you
had some especially over this filibuster
some strong words oh yeah yeah it was
pretty tough although you know as bill
hathaway said that the great advantage
of the senate is there's no heavy
lifting involved you know former senator
from maine
bill hathaway the reason why i mentioned
it is you you left the senate before it
went on television yes
it wasn't until 1986. you think that
whole episode of the filibuster you
might tell us a little bit about that
would have happened if you'd have been
on television oh yeah i think
surely it would have yeah i think in
fact we'd probably had more filibusters
had we had television
but we did the filibuster to try to
defeat
the natural gas deregulation bill
that was 1977 when we started on it
and
we thought that because it was going the
deregulation seemed to be slipping
through so quietly that we had to call
attention to it to get the public aware
of what was happening so they could
pressure
the senate and the house into not
deregulating natural gas we accomplished
that purpose partially
but when when jimmy carter changed
positions he was originally on our side
against deregulation he switched
positions and came out for it later on
while we were defeated there was not
much we could do because we relied upon
carter
to switch the two or three votes
necessary to defeat the bill and we
didn't get the help from him that we
should have
and you said that after that filibuster
experience you have a whole chapter on
the filibuster in here uh they changed
the rules
they did change the rules yeah it's much
harder to conduct that kind of a
post-cloture filibuster now but i
thought in all the years i thought it
was interesting in all the years that
the southern senators filibustered to
prevent civil rights legislation
and that senator allen from alabama
filibustered to prevent anti-trust
legislation from going through
that they only changed the rules when
howard metzenbaum and i filibustered on
behalf of the consumer i thought it was
very interesting about the u.s senate do
you think that they actually tried to
change the rules because of what you did
with this filibuster yes well of course
yeah they up there
in in the senate they call that the
abress commitment
it was changed after i left the senate
but it was because of abraham what's the
main difference now well the difference
now is that uh
well before you have to know what it was
before if you introduced an amendment
prior to cloture prior to the time
cloche was voted
uh that amendment could be called up
after cloture was voted so i had 508
amendments introduced
those amendments were not counted
against the time
because after cloture every senator gets
only one hour to speak
unless he gets unanimous consent to
extend that time
well
now these amendments as i understand it
are counted again any amendment you call
up or counted against your one hour so
you really can't call up very many
amendments now
but it was virtually unlimited back in
those days and that allowed you to do a
filibuster
tell a story about uh i believe he's the
late john sparkman senator sparkman yes
alabama
is this the one about the the prime
minister of botswana yes sir
oh yes yeah i wasn't there by the way
that story was told me by another
senator who was there but john you know
unfortunately he was a good man by the
way but he suffered from narcolepsy or
that you know he fell asleep
at almost any time during the day
uncontrollable i couldn't control it
yeah it was just you know just a it's a
disease it's like any other disease
the prime minister of botswana came to
the foreign relations committee for
lunch one day
and he was sitting next to a senator
sparkman
and john introduced him sparkman
introduced him
and the prime minister in his eclipt
oxford accent
said well he says i'm most happy to be
here today
i said the last time i was in washington
the country's attention was turned
toward watergate in vietnam and the
problems of africa were pushed on the
back burner he said i'm so happy to see
that you finally turned your attention
your your sound attention to africa
today and just at that time john
sparkman fell asleep and his head
came over on the prime minister's
shoulder who had to push him away
it was a
magnificent bit of timing i thought
and this story was you had a television
station owner in your statement the name
of joe floyd
yep still there and you were on a
committee that was going to hear from
the president of cbs news arthur taylor
yes
what happened well uh joe called me up
joe was one of my great supporters
called me up and he said jim
i said art taylor is going to be a
president of cbs he said i'd like you to
go to the hearings and sort of you know
help him out i said i don't want to go
i don't want to go to those hearings
i've got other work to do joe no he says
i'm that's the only request i've ever
made if you just go to the hearings so i
went up there and phil hart was chairing
the
the hearings it was his subcommittee
former senator from michigan now
deceased yes right
i i was sitting there doodling you know
just
whiling away the time trying to get back
to my office
when phil hart passed me a note
he said i've got to go to the senate
floor can you take over as chairman of
this subcommittee
i said all right so i listened to one
other witness then art taylor arthur
taylor came up
and
i guess fully expecting i was going to
be his friend on the committee
probably joe floyd had told him
so taylor started talking about the
great benefits of free television as
opposed to pay television they were
trying to defeat
uh pay cable tv back then
such as hbo and showtime and so on
and i listened to him for a long time
and it was getting so bad that i
suddenly i just couldn't take it anymore
and i said wait a minute you mean free
television until the time you buy a tube
of toothpaste or or a bottle of underarm
deodorant right mr taylor
and we got into the most horrendous
argument i mean he didn't like what i
said obviously
i don't blame him
we got into a horrible argument and the
the hearing broke up you know just on a
very sour note
and i went back to the office
and
joe floyd called me and he said well
how'd the hearings go and i said well
sorry joe
i think i've been in your eyes a very
bad boy
when did you and we only had a couple
minutes left when did you know
that what you saw in the senate you
didn't like
i suppose the first few months i was
there what were a couple of things that
you started to notice that you said this
just does i'm uncomfortable about this
well you know i i was in in 73 the first
time is when i first went in
and we were trying to get the vietnam
war stopped and i could not believe
that
that this united states senate was
incapable of stopping it they were very
cowardly i mean not all of them you know
there was a very staunch group who were
trying to end the war
but the majority were cowardly they just
didn't they were afraid to do it for
fear they'd be blamed for losing vietnam
as though we owned vietnam
i mean this war was killing people on
both sides on our side on the other side
it was the most senseless thing i could
ever see you know this this
so-called deal to bring democracy to the
world you know you can't kill everybody
just to bring democracy
and
i remember the big debate on uh on
ending the bombing
uh and and senators got up and i
couldn't believe what i heard you know i
mean i was really disillusioned
that they were absolutely afraid to put
an end to the bombing and an end to the
funding of the war
that was the first bit of uh
of the disillusionment i added many
other times of course but you know
people are disillusioned all through
their lives
that's really
that's really not the cause of all all
things but
our guest for the last hour has been
james abarisk
here's what the book looks like it's
called advise and descent
memoirs of a south dakota
of south dakota and the u.s senate in
your bookstores
thank you very much for joining us
advise and descent by james aberask is
currently out of print visit an online
bookseller or your local used bookstore
for more information
next week on encore book notes new
yorker columnist ken oletta
for information about any authors and
books featured on encore